[Music]
we begin with that breaking news israel
is accusing hezbollah of launching what
it's calling an
infiltration attempt on its border with
lebanon
it happened in the past couple of hours
in the sheba farms region
there's been no confirmation as yet from
hezbollah that it was behind the
incident the united nations is urging
restraint
from both sides israel's prime minister
benjamin netanyahu was posted on twitter
saying what was happening on the
northern border was being constantly
monitored
he says israel won't allow iran to
establish itself
on the border netanyahu adds that
lebanon and hezbollah will be
responsible
for any attack out of lebanon
we have two correspondents working on
this story harry fawcett is live for us
in west jerusalem in just a few moments
but first let's join zeta hodder who's
on the lebanon side
of that border with israel zainab what's
the latest
a much awaited statement from the
lebanese armed group hezbollah released
just a short while ago hezbollah denying
that there was
any sort of attack in the statement it
says
there was no operation today there was
no
exchange of fire we did not open fire it
was the israelis who opened fire
and the statements adds that the israeli
army is in a state of confusion
we do know that there has been tension
along this border for
the past few days now ever since
it was confirmed that a hezbollah
fighter was killed in what was believed
to be an israeli airstrike in syria
and everyone was waiting for the
possible hezbollah retaliation because
hezbollah promised in the past that any
if any of its fighters are killed in
syria it will
retaliate so hezbollah now saying that
there was no operation
the israeli army initially said that
there was a security incident
and then it went on to explain that
a group of hezbollah fighters tried to
infiltrate the shabbat farm so
conflicting
narratives here on what exactly happened
behind me
behind those hills is shiva farms
a disputed area disputed territory a
land that
intersects syria israel and
lebanon and it's quite significant that
if indeed there was some sort of
operation that hezbollah has now
denied to choose this area because it's
disputed it means that hezbollah does
not want to escalate the situation
any sort of operation there it can
easily justify by saying that it is
defending
lebanese territory in the eyes of
lebanon this territory shabbat farms
belongs to
it uh but the status of shiva has not
been settled by the international
community because lebanon and syria have
still not demarcated
uh their border so hezbollah now saying
that there was no operation and now
saying that it was the israeli army
that's confused
really criticizing if you if you like
the israeli army
but i can tell you that lebanese
security source told al jazeera
a moment after the israeli army reported
a security incident
that some sort of incident
or attack or reconnaissance mission but
something happened along this border al
jazeera zaina hoda reporting live there
from the lebanon side of the border with
israel let's bring in al jazeera's harry
forsett who's in west jerusalem
uh harry what's israel saying about what
happened on the border
well yes the israeli military as uh just
reporting
is saying that there was an attempt to
infiltrate by
a cell of three to five hezbollah
fighters
uh into israeli-controlled territory in
the occupied golan heights in
the shaiba farms area that they tracked
this cell before they entered israeli
territory they came into or israeli
controlled territory
they came a few meters inside that
territory and that they were driven back
the israeli military says by uh machine
gun fire tank fire
and artillery now during the course and
just after the course
of this incident the israeli military
instructed all civilians
to remain indoors in the area about an
hour later
they went back to normal procedures
allowing people
uh back onto the roads and into open
spaces once again signaling that from
the israeli perspective
things seem to have returned to a lower
level of alert and insecurity
but as far as the israelis are concerned
they're saying that there was an attempt
they have been waiting for such an
attempt for days now since that strike
inside syria in which a hezbollah
fighter was killed
and as far as they were concerned they
were preempting or responding to
such an attempt to infiltrate their
territory al jazeera
harry fawcett live in west jerusalem
harry many thanks